おおいい質問だ中世の頃も政府に良かった英語の体とが100件中16点でした
今日は外してとですでちょっと連続でもされないですけども器グリーン
新しいの準備しました
みなさん今回のすごいです4つのメジャー調べてみましょうか
けっこう前に買ったんですけどお店から僕の体の大きさ見て回れたの首回りとか星とか
全部のパーツがオーダーメイドで僕しか着れない形で作ってもらいました
来た来たこれですこれ値段がなんと
うーん同12万に設計や県で
ちょっとあが入っ
まず高いですけど別なものになりきるということにすごい興味があります始めた
チャベス2で今回のケーブル日はこちら
これで箱2つなんですよ今回で先を言ったんですけども完全オーダーメイド俺が旧ため
だけに作られた
42枚の復帰組ね日暮れ目にこんなにを招くけど全然ないからちょっと結構楽しみです
いや皆さん江
今回はあ
期待しててくださいいきまーす
あっ浜ねー
細草やマイナーこれでめちゃくちゃパーツが細かいと
ちょっとの間いうとこれがあっハヌルがパーってこの空りてぃですこれもオレの腕の
サイズに作られてるから
バッツに入るんですねおおよそこの課税させることができると思うんですけども
どんどん上げていきましょう
これどーこーだー
さあ多分足これに感謝をわからんいやーここからすごくオーナーを
味パーツ
yeah かっこええ
なにこれなにこれたたたた分でタブーで
じゃこりゃーは毛束から凍って号います
足脚レグザ不動態そしてこれがタブー
顔ですパーツだけ見るとマジで怖い今外科で着ぐるみ
ローンとの日組です
420,000円ですよでもでもクオリティや理由なにこれやっぱ4図2番取った子所
になるんですね
完全に42万個れているんだとか女光ってるんですよこれも頭が悪いで計ってるんで
完璧にかぶることができますがほぼ何も見えません
雑感気になったポイントがありましてあの説明書が無いんですね
売り切れるん消えるところが来てみます俺の現場わかるのでもあ c はカモ君松栄町
まで意味わかんなすぎだよ
こうだろうなぁ多分つもりだしにフィットしてんだけど
[音楽]
僕気づいた水色よく所栗というわけでくるって書いてきましただ気づかなかったんで
あれこういう隙間の部分はミールんで
加え服が絶対いいと思いますよもう1回ちゃんと来ていきますまず脚な
こーだそーだそーだ俺は太もも大貴族たち
ここだああ
は水やばああああ
[音楽]
お知らせはい足はきました
ん
なんで毎回こんなきついんだろう歩き方もロボとなっちゃう
[音楽]
じゃっぺ
ニードル月だけ
[音楽]
ています
あ振動あればまず言ってんだこれこんなのだりするとある
そうね1人ジブリっ麻生は完璧だったんですけどちょっと胴体マジで難しいな
ちょっとこれ個人などつけられないレベルということがはっきり分かったので一回ね
ます
二人なら多分切れると思ってつけておこうと思います
ん
持った
samsung いや俺やばいでしょうかね5星方を破れ
ちょっと動いますねーよあーんだよ
マジローっだからん
[音楽]
う5型デイこれ受けるんですけどこれこれこれぞそう思いでその上手く表現できるん
ですけどあー
着ぐるみずじゃぁないしでこれ飾った土井で腕とかもこれで限界なんですよ
佐竹ですね一応良い道尻てきます同衣装パック3
5人間じゃないと思われそうだと思うんですよ腕も誇れるちょっと見えてんだよなぁ
完全にロボットの状態ではーゲットの家の前に
みようと思いますよ行ってきます
[音楽]
持った
エロティカん
ん
ぷっ
ブーブー
ん
んん
th
ええええええ
ん
ブーム
me
ええええええ
が打って守って
ん
できなかったけどね
は
がことですか
ブンブンん
計画
ええええええ
持っています
ん
tre ん
ブーブー
ん
4日
ad ん
[音楽]
th
5もらう
[音楽]
の
me
re 掘った
お手2ん
います
2ん
ウール f
goo
[音楽]
car
wh
あっはぁ
[音楽]
blp へ